let's jump into this story right away we
got this from timcast.com Project
Veritas releases video of Pfizer exec
discussing mutating covid-19 with
directed Evolution the reason for
wanting to mutate the virus Walker told
an undercover journalist is so that the
company can stay ahead of the game and
continue to profit from the vaccines
quote one of the things we are exploring
is like why don't we just mutate it
ourselves so we could create
preemptively develop new vaccines right
so we have to do that if we're going to
do that though there's a risk of like as
you can imagine no one wants to be
having a Pharma company mutating effing
viruses Walker said Walker continued
from what I've heard is the Pfizer
scientists are optimizing covet mutation
process but they're going slow because
everyone is very cautious obviously they
don't want to accelerate it too much I
think they are also just trying to do it
as an exploratory thing because you
obviously don't want to advertise that
you are figuring out future mutations
I'm just going to pause right there in
the video with with uh this this Pfizer
this is the director of strategic
director of research and development
strategic operations he says no no no
it's not getting a function research
you're not allowed to do gain of
function research it's directed
Evolution to explore Advance you know
evolving this virus
this is crazy stuff he goes on to say
well he's got a bunch of quotes here let
me see if I can search for this and see
if they've uh put the quote here on
Wuhan he says quote you have to be very
controlled to make sure that this virus
coveted that you mutate doesn't create
something that just goes everywhere
which I suspect is the way that the
virus started in Wuhan to be honest it
makes no sense that this virus popped
out of nowhere it's bullish this is to
stress Jordan Tristan Walker Pfizer
director of research and development
strategic operations saying he believes
kovid originated in a Wuhan lab due to
directed Evolution mutation research as
he calls it the crazy thing is
I don't I I I don't have the sources
here to to back all this up it's just
what I'm hearing that we're going to be
getting more information from the
Veritas team when they confronted this
guy and said we have you on camera
admitting to these things he then
physically attacked the project Veritas
crew security had to intervene and
subdue him and the police actually got
involved and asked if they wanted to
press charges Veritas said no I don't
know the full details on that and I will
just say that is alleged for now but I
can't wait to see that video I don't
think Veritas is the kind of crew or the
kind of group who's going to say
something unless they have it on camera
especially concerning the smears that
are out against them so take that one
you know hold it back for a little bit
but that is crazy to hear so whenever I
I so here's what happens James does
these the undercover journalists will
will interview somebody get them to talk
about it this guy candidly says don't
tell anybody here's what we're doing
they then get the footage James O'Keefe
then confronts them he says we have you
on camera saying these things he does it
all the time we've seen it all the time
so when I'm hearing that they got
attacked sounds believable to me
um you know
I really want them to uh test this on
Turtles and then name the Turtles
Michelangelo
Nutella record yeah
I'll be mean to the turtles though man
it would be well I mean if they had a
mutagen that would make my turtles large
humanoid sentient ninjas I'd be like
okay well maybe that's not a bad thing
Turtles might enjoy that yeah you know
yeah they could be crime Fighters you
never know no but the crazy thing is
they're doing it on monkeys this guy
talks about how he's like basically you
you give the monkey the virus and then
you isolate the the more virulent strain
and then you keep forcing it and and
it's crazy and you can direct the
evolution and make it do these things yo
it sounds like gain of function recently
I was getting ready to say it I'm like
you say it's not gained a function but
then go on to describe gain of function
yeah it's exactly what he did it's like
saying my wife going oh I don't go to
Target I go to Target
[Applause]
it's like without you did yeah when
fauci was in the hearing with Rand Paul
and Rand Paul's like I have here a
document saying you to gain a function
research in fact she's like we didn't do
gain of function research which of
course is evolving a virus we just
altered a virus by by having it change
over time and it's like okay dude you
know what man you've got such a great
vouching yeah I mean it's it's meant to
be like derisively over the top it
sounds safe though no what does yeah
just take the virus and you just mutated
and mutate that sounds really that's how
Ebola was started bro was it yeah it
could it couldn't it couldn't affect
humans it got taught to really yeah is
that I don't I've never heard that is
that true yeah that's I had looked it up
that's a hotep take right there that's
not exclusive
yeah right that sounds like
non-mainstream knowledge if you know
what I mean it's not mainstream
knowledge I'll say it like that he's
loyal to the full
they're like you're gonna get you're
gonna get Media Matters riding up crazy
conspiracy they're gonna write those I
don't know anyways yeah don't worry
about it last night
and on conspiracy theorist Cannon Hotel
yes well you know they're gonna they're
gonna come outside this Veritas stuff is
fake they're gonna say this guy's just
making things up yeah and that's the
craziest thing I mean maybe but like
let's entertain that like why would this
guy
sitting down to dinner with some dinner
presumably on a date why would he come
out and be like hey here's all the dirty
stuff we're doing yeah maybe I guess he
felt like he was impressing the person
that he's he's out all of the body
language is him like sitting forward and
being like Oh my gosh so fun you
mentioned on the date that could be why
he is because he felt like he he
betrayed him if they were on a date and
it's like and he comes up he's he it
could be I don't know I don't know man
why don't you love me no I it could be I
think if they assuming that the tax
story is is correct I'm waiting for the
confirmation it's because this guy
basically is admitting to like Global
level international incident
malfeasance but we we you know well we
can't find his LinkedIn page already so
I don't know they did a lot of work
trying to find it right but like it's
not obvious he's obviously clearly proud
of like what position he's in he's
willing to talk about it pretty openly
like I'm surprised that it's not more
obvious who this person is unless Pfizer
is oh we terminated that person several
weeks ago he was talking so a matter of
factly about it like he it was just it
was just rolling off the tongue we uh we
wrote this sketch for James we we
haven't we haven't done and I don't know
if we ever will so I'll just tell people
what the sketch was that we wrote for
for project Veritas and it's that one of
the employees at timcast keeps seeing in
the corner of his eye like James O'Keefe
like filming him from a distance and
like lurking around he's getting all
paranoid like James O'Keefe is filming
me man and we're like dude James O'Keefe
is not filming you and then like one day
he sees James like in the woods he's
like staring at him and it runs off and
then finally at the end of of the bit
he's like guys I'm really sorry I got so
paranoid and thought James O'Keefe was
filming me obviously he's not out to get
me and we're like thank you oh and then
we're like so what are you doing tonight
and he goes oh I got a date and then
James O'Keefe walks up in a wig and then
and then the guy goes come here baby let
me tell you about some corporate
malfeasance I'm involved in but like the
point of the joke is all of these people
like basically what what Veritas has
been very successful at is they go on
Tinder dates they go on Tinder in a
certain area and they see you like they
keep swiping until they find Pfizer
executive or whatever but then these
guys are on dates with these young women
and they're like let me tell you about
the illegal things I'm doing and it's
just are they impressing women by saying
this like yeah kind of Claire would you
be impressed if a guy come to you and
said let me tell you about all the
illegal things I'm involved in
um I think people would I wouldn't
personally be impressed but I think
people will say stuff like that to be
like look I'm not just like someone who
works in the office like I have in
information I have decision making power
like it's a posturing right it's like I
think I would keep them talking I think
I would want to know what they're doing
but like it's not that I would be like
well let's have a second date yeah
that's a bad look that's a bad look you
know I couldn't imagine any woman being
attracted to the man after he just
snitched on the company
it reminds me of like guys who are like
I have this kind of car like whatever
else like unless she's also interested
what is this is worse demonstrating
because value well there's no loyalty
there right so like this is the first
impression you're on a date with the
girl and it's like I don't even have
loyalty to people that cut my checks I'm
gonna tell you their deepest darkest
dirt so if I'm a chick I'm like well
what are you gonna do with the
information I tell you right like that's
gotta drive the Yoni up but also look at
the guys and the women that they take
out they tell this stuff they don't look
like they had much of a social life
that's true yeah and then you get
somebody that looks like an eight or a
10. you don't really got much exciting
have you guys seen that Meme where it's
like the the access axis of like women
and it's it's the hot hot uh yeah so
somebody took it because all the crazy
zero but super hot was it said unicorn
someone took that and changed unicorn to
James O'Keefe like guys if you are a
frumpy dude of moderate means and the
hottest chick in the world is asking
about corporate malfeasance at your
company is James O'Keefe come on it's
just what it is you're being set up in
some sort of fashion yeah I mean if
you're like rich or something or you're
like a tall model guy is all chiseled
you understand like you know why this
chick's into you but yeah these these
guys they fall for it every single time
well and they like talking about it
that's my point like if there's a girl
and maybe you're like a little so
shocker you don't know what to talk
about on this date and she keeps being
like so tell me more about your job oh
my gosh you can do that you can release
the mrnas some kind of Spidey station
I'll tell you whatever you want yeah but
to be Fair like when someone is on a
date when you're talking about yourself
like that you're trying to put on the
best be as impressive as you can be and
you don't obviously they don't want to
seem over the top but they also want to
seem interesting enough to have earned a
second date and if you're you know if
you if you are like kind of a homebody
or a dude that's like you know kind of a
nerd dude or whatever or a bookish kind
of person you're out on a date you get
that this is your chance to go ahead and
show off and stunt and actually be in a
position where you know what you're
talking about you're gonna grab that and
you're gonna be like let me ride this
all the way into six town especially she
keeps asking that's the one thing this
girl wants to talk about this is the
number one mistake men make on dates
with women they talk about themselves
what do we know about women women love
talking about themselves if you let a
woman talk about herself all night at
the end of the night she's gonna be like
oh you're a really nice guy I'm like no
I just let you talk I just wanted to
talk you have no idea you didn't ask me
any questions she'll never ask you any
questions it'll be at the end of the day
oh okay so tell me about you it's like
yeah two hours dinner and whatnot right
just like check please but then they
called their friends and like he's such
a good listener it's so nice and that's
that's what you want to go for that just
happens to be my strength I'm a really
really good listener so you know that's
what girls would say oh you're such a
really good listen like yeah that is you
know but I think guys can learn from
that like you don't have to go on a date
if she's on a date with you she has some
level of respect You've Won some some
you know level of uh trust I guess you
can say unless you look like Chris
Farley and she looks like Cyndi Lauper
somebody somebody's definitely set up
because to your point uh like if she's
constantly asking you about your job and
you know your job is some kind of like
you got some clearance or something like
that yeah you should be really wary
about why she keeps asking about
especially considering the topic too
like I mean if you're in that business
or if you're around that kind of stuff
and like it's like presumably you're not
like taking her to your office on like a
second date right like theoretically
there'd be some other conversation like
so do you like movies like it's the only
thing you want to talk about is the
Pfizer vaccine I mean but here's the
thing we gotta know the batting average
I want to see the girls he sends out and
see what is their batting average like
is it one out of ten guys that fall for
it I imagine he sends out our top secret
like that is like yeah but what is that
batting average right like right success
rate with getting somebody to snitch I
doubt he's sending out tens you know
like model looking women with thousands
of fun they're probably like moderately
attractive women so these guys are
excited but then you make a good point
how many times has James O'Keefe sent
out a crew yeah and they come back with
nothing nothing yeah that's what I want
to know I wonder I bet a lot yeah it
might be a numbers game right like oh
one of these dupes there's 10 guys
working father one of these dupes gonna
there was a one of the Twitter guys we
talked about this I felt bad because he
like
he was complaining about I think it was
on Twitter guys complaining about
malfeasance at Twitter saying they do
these things they're bad I don't like it
blah blah yeah and so he wasn't really a
bad guy he should call it out but then
it's like imagine you're this dude and
you're on a date and this girl's opening
up to you she's asking you about your
interests she's kind of attractive
you're like man this is this is I feel I
feel cared about is so great and then
like a day later she's like bro I'm just
secretly recording you to expose your
company I have no interest any time
that's like that's like the scene from
Indiana Jones where he does the kaliman
rips the heart out and you're like oh I
feel bad for these guys that's got to be
devastating yeah because my red flag in
this video the minute he said game of
function I'd have been like yeah how do
you know what that means how do you know
them where'd that come from you know
what I mean yeah Alex Jones right yeah
and and you'd think like these these
guys would be on guard and the first
thing they do at a dinner date or
whatever is like so do you listen Alex
Jones be like yeah all right later
you're James O'Keefe where is he no but
I'm telling you it's like so they can
seem cool right like they're bragging
about the job and all this information
they have and you seem interested so
it's like oh I can tell you this kind of
Insider thing like that's not like
totally implausible in dating right
everyone like you said like wants to
seem like them their best selves on a
first date but like if you suddenly feel
like you're wielding power and this
person is impressed with it like you're
more likely to try and show off and in
this case like yeah because they're not
good they're not gonna be able to date
like they look look
I'm a level 10 wizard in my Dungeons and
Dragons
if you play your cards right I'll let
you come to the game no no no no no this
is what I want to see James project
Veritas I know you guys have a lot of
donors who give you money on ideological
grounds like expose the bad guys but you
know there's the Veritas b-sides where
it's like sitting down within it with a
with a big Pharma executive works for
like you know Eli Lilly and the chick's
like so like what do you get what do you
do at work I don't know stuff I'm a
level 10 Rogue by the way me and my
buddies you know we're gonna do d d
tonight yeah well like what do you do at
work you know I don't know collate
papers but hey check it out I got this
character I would love to watch that
you're talking about you're talking
about project Veritas garage days
re-revisited no I want to know what girl
was like so committed to figuring out
that she's like I'm gonna figure out
with how this game works tell me how the
cards get laid on table I got it we need
either Freedom Tunes we need like Ryan
long we got the skit the skit is of
veritas journalist is doing an
undercover staying on a big Tech
executive but they actually fall in love
and then the big Tech guy is like if
they find out I'm dating a Veritas
journalist I'll be fired and she's like
if Veritas finds out I've fallen in love
with you I'll be fired and they they run
away and elope together like Romeo and
Juliet someone call Hallmark right now
that's their next speaker I just want to
say like we're supposed to be talking
about this very serious like action this
is very serious we're dissecting you
know how to catch these guys right this
is important so for example so for
example do these girls have previous
experience when they apply for this job
or is James training them and what does
the training program look like so it's
like spy program someone super chatted
they train them
yeah these these you know young women
get trained on how to get people to talk
about these things how did how do you
like what is this Ted does it look like
Men In Black the movie where like you're
trying to have them you know take a test
like did you see three four five on the
screen or you know I gotta be honest
it's not that easy to get people to talk
about this stuff you you sit down for
dinner and you say thanks for meeting
how are you you'd warm up a little bit
you say so what do you what do you do
for work and oh I work for uh Twitter
and I'd be like oh cool what's that like
you let them talk you ask like I was
hearing something in the news about like
Congress or something I didn't really
follow it and they'll be like oh yeah
there was like bias against
conservatives and then you go oh is that
true like are they doing that that's it
it's not even that difficult
social engineering social engineering
that is fine this is what they're doing
I mean I have some level of smarts you
can't just be a complete idiot and take
this but a lot of people they'd be
bursting at the seams wanting to talk
about things I see what you're saying
and then when you get somebody that
seems like they're kind of interested
and they're kind of like hey come on
something something yeah then they kind
of just start
letting it go you're that's 100 it must
be it must be very difficult for for
Veritas to train uh these young women to
be manipulative into getting men to give
them what they want you know what I mean
they want to know if they're like so
have you ever tapped your boyfriend's
phone like how do they scream like
that's what I'm saying previous
experience yeah they gotta jump they
gotta get jumped in like in the gang
like I need you to go home and I need
you to I need you to put this song I
know what you do I know how to do it
what if what if someone applies for
project Veritas and is also an
undercover journalist trying to you know
yeah double agent here's what I would do
I take all the girls in the room
and the first one to pull some dirt out
of the other girl is the one who gets
the job
got some big brother stuff you got a
surprise him because you're gonna you're
gonna get like a Washington Post
reporter being like I want to work and
I'm this like you got to figure out if
they're legitimate or not yeah that's a
tough thing yeah but but you know a
Pfizer is looking out for our best
interest let's just call it speed of
spade right this this uh research is
important right yeah it's good for
everyone probably like the thing that
I'm really interested in finding or
interested in seeing is like what is
this information is anything going to
happen from this like there's already a
significant portion of the population
that doesn't trust uh the the
vaccinations and stuff like that uh
regardless of of what anyone has taken
or has not taken the vaccines it's like
there's a lot of people out there that
are really dead set against it what's
this going to do to you know with the
house being controlled by Republicans
are they going to actually start having
uh um investigations
I mean I gotta say like this actually is
this is real
this is This lends itself more to the
conspiracy that the vaccines actually
are intended to stop the virus this guy
is saying he believes the virus was
essentially manufactured and then
accidentally released yeah and so I've
often talked about that because the
people who are like you know you've got
you've got right now uh that's suddenly
documentary you've got 300 000 excess
deaths in uh I think in young people or
in general in general in the United
States no no I think it's young people
300 000 excess deaths not attributed to
covid and everybody comes out
immediately just says the vaccine and
I'm like well hold on it could be
covered and then people say no they
don't think it is and I'm like yo people
were coming out a year ago two years ago
saying that kovid was a bioweapon
manufactured in a lab that leaked now
y'all are saying no we don't think this
is the cause of people having heart
attacks and stuff like that I'm just
saying I don't know you know I always
say talk to a doctor you know and trust
but don't definitively State you know
one conspiracy theory over another if
like any one of them could be
hypothetical hypothetically plausible or
whatever but yeah I mean I get what
you're saying because
either way you gotta recognize the
correlation that when either or either
one of these things came out
death Spike we saw we we saw the videos
before the vaccine of people collapsing
in the street yeah yeah then we see
people today doing it and they're like
oh that must be the vaccine I'm like why
that was happening before the vaccine
well Scott Adams asked a very
interesting question today right like if
you were on the alter alternative side
of things how was I supposed to know I
should listen to you right it's a very
valid question
um we have an internal guy Dr tonight
Ricks he's an organic chemist and
professor and when he said something
about the PCR testing it turned out to
be true he did a threat on this so I
think what it comes down to is you
always need a debate whenever you find
out that there's something that people
don't agree on let's have a debate on
you bring your experts to the table I
bring my experts to the table but what
we found with this conversation was
these experts were the primary source
and everybody else was fake news they
must be banned they must be ostracized
everything yeah everybody was vilified
so that best of red flag to me like wait
I can't have these doctors cross-examine
the work of your doctors and bring that
to the front and let us make the
decision it's the Alexander Hamilton
argument for the Central Bank where they
say no we have to think for the people
because we can't trust them to make
decisions based upon their own
recognizance which has the inverse of
the Streisand Effect essentially yes you
end up with a bunch of people saying you
know what I'm going to believe the
opposite because you banned it right
that's that frustrates me to be honest
because I understand but it's not Sound
Logic to be like they banned talking
about X therefore X must be true no no
that doesn't follow it just means the
sensors are bad people yeah and it means
they're stifling legitimate conversation
making it harder for us to figure out
what's really going on but I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna take any tribal side in
any of these debates here's what I did
uh I called I did the only thing a smart
person would do when I got sick as I
called the expert Joe Rogan right and uh
asked him you know he said call the
doctor he said talk to a doctor and so I
called a private he said talk to a talk
to like a private practice Yeah and then
I did and then we got monoclonal
antibodies yeah we got uh prescribed
that we got prescribed uh
anti-inflammatory like steroids or
something
um what else do we get we got some other
stuff and then we did prescribed
Ivermectin which I said I didn't want I
I attribute the treatment that helped me
monoclonal antibodies and was way better
after that and then didn't even care
about the evermectum but the doctor
insisted that I take it and uh then
Daily Beast wrote a smear about me
saying I was the poster boy for
Ivermectin when I literally said I
didn't want it I didn't think it did
anything I went on Joe's show and said I
don't think it did anything yeah it's
crazy the problem is you've got
corporate media lying about everything
and then you get a lot of people say if
they said it the opposite must be true
and I'm like well maybe most of the time
that may be the case to be completely
honest yeah like the media lies so much
if they come out and say Donald Trump
did a backflip I'd assume he did a front
flip you know well and you probably make
it you make more money on your bets if
you go that route I think you have to
have some level of uh ability to manage
the conversation for example if somebody
asks you why why you believe in that you
should have some evidence some
ammunition to back up your claims on you
know why right like if we said something
about PCR tests and the amount of cycles
that they were doing this is what's
creating false positives you sound
something like you know what's going on
right
um but I think a lot of times like you
said people are making that gambling
guess right like this must be true but
you got to look into it you got to know
for yourself what the truth is and why
you know the alternative side might be
right at least have a source and say hey
I don't know the particulars but go talk
to Dr tonight Ricks right if you can't
yeah a doctor like if you can't point
just the expert for other people to say
all right I'm gonna ask him now right
then that's when it's like you can't
even back up what you're saying and it's
a little suspicious and then now the
people who are following the mainstream
can't trust you because you're just
saying oh I'm just going this way
because I'm a conspiracy theorist and
that's banned that's the band opinion no
give people sources they have the meme
you know conspiracy theorists 10 you
know major media zero and stuff like
that and you're like yeah you know for
sure like we totally get that but uh the
thing the thing that people don't
understand is like the doctor you're
referencing you're talking about you're
talking about a doctor right you know
when people talk about
um Peter McCullough is that his name
right yeah or Pierre Corey uh doctor
alone we're talking about doctors
doctors have opinions now the problem of
course is they censored these doctors
then you had the Frontline care doctors
like these are doctors so when I tell
people talk to a doctor that you trust
who can answer the questions and is a
medical professional license and all
that stuff like there are a lot of
people who say yeah but the doctor's so
dumb to him and I'm like look doctors
are not one person if you go to a doctor
and they can't answer any of this stuff
they have no what you're talking about
second opinion well it's not even that
it's like bro if I want here's the
analogy I give if I call the plumbers my
toilet broke and then he goes I got no
idea how Plumbing Works I'd be like okay
I gotta hire a plumber who does yeah if
you go to a doctor and you say hey this
is the thing I'm experienced and I read
this and I read that what is this all
about and the doctor's like I have no
idea well dude like yeah you need to
find a doctor who can tell you about
medical ailments and studies and the
research and if you go to one who can't
then it's not like you went to a doctor
you know well that's how I navigated the
Bitcoin world in the crypto world I
didn't know what's going on I'm not one
of those guys so I got two guys of
opposing opinions and had them debate
live in front of me and what you'll find
is this guy will ask that guy a question
and you can tell if this guy knows what
he's talking about even if you don't
understand what he's saying you can kind
of tell by his Mandarin but if he hits
you with the uh well you know uh then
he's like oh wait you can't answer that
question that guy just asked you and
then that's how you can sort of navigate
that conversation not just that if they
can't come terribly admit to a lack of
knowledge is a red flag conversation you
know I was watching uh I want to give a
shout out to uh Lex Friedman Lex
Friedman you know we we've read on them
I've I've watched some of his Clips but
uh the one show of his I really really
want to watch is uh I guess he did an
episode with Daniel negrano the poker
player okay and he's talking about I've
only seen the clips because I've been
watching a bunch of Poker videos I've
been having a lot of fun playing online
poker he's talking about planting ideas
in people's minds he's talking about
trying to figure out what card somebody
has trying to figure out what they're
thinking trying to figure out if they're
playing you and that is so much of of
real life if you're sitting down and you
see two people and you're like guys is
it is is the left path the right way is
the right path the right way which
direction do I go and one guy says
listen
in 1973 the left path was documented as
having more potholes than the right now
doesn't mean that today there's still
more potholes but you're better off the
guy on the left says that's not true
that's fake news he's lying he's lying
about potholes okay well which one do
you think makes more sense well this guy
actually cited some some data point I've
not checked it but he's warning me about
paddles this guy's just saying it's not
true yes then you go to the guy on the
left and say okay why do you think
there's no potholes he said there were
he cites this study what do you have to
say uh well uh well the thing is yeah
right there's a red flag because if you
go to the guy on the other side and say
what is he saying about this this thing
not being true he says it was debunked
well look I haven't read any of those
studies suggesting it was debunked you
should probably look it up but I can
only tell you that the studies I've read
said X yeah when someone can confidently
tell you you know what that's a good
point I'm not entirely sure so I
encourage you to follow up that is the
more honest approach yeah of course then
you can get somebody who might try to
manipulate you knowing how to play those
games but that's the word discernment
politics right like you have to be able
to discern based upon body language
having
uh some level of knowledge on the
subject matter to be able to decipher
the BS from the real right like I don't
know crypto in depth but if you try to
BS me I know when you're bsing same
thing a little bit with health and
biology you know if they start talking
about things if you have a basic
understanding of science sometimes you
can pick apart when somebody's using
words and not saying anything because
you'll get a lot of that yeah shout out
uh you're our resident 2A guy right here
who's that dude who's like he's a
Democrat and he claims he's like I was a
marine you know when we would go out our
our rifles were kept in lockers and blah
blah and he was like an administrator
who wasn't even armed or something like
that yeah you get these people who say
listen I was a marine I can tell you
about guns we have to do it this way and
and then anybody who knows anything
about guns is like this guy is so full
yeah I think people being like Oh well I
was in the military so I know a ton
about it like my older brother was
Marine he regularly was like I I don't
know a ton about guns I know what I
learned to go through training but I am
no by no means any expert for everyone
there are people who weren't military
who were just passionate about the
subject and learn all about it I find
that I'm wary when people start to treat
it like you're supposed to accept it as
common knowledge right so whether it's
vaccines or anything in the whole world
like being like well it's just what
everyone like this is just the way it is
this is just whatever believes oh
everyone knows that and they can't say
specifically why we know that or where
it comes from that's when I start to be
like well you need to present both sides
of the information evidence and sources
that's what we want to see evidence and
sources if one side can provide evidence
and sources he's probably more likely to
be believable but the other side always
provide ad hominem
emotionalism yeah they're just trying to
discredit you based off of popular
opinion
and then come on and say oh like for
example Neil deGrasse Tyson when he was
on uh I forgot the podcast Patrick about
yeah on his podcast he was like well
there's a social contract that you can't
go out here and infect people and
basically he was saying then he also
said for lack of a better term he was
like
well basically people are too stupid to
understand the nomenclature so they just
got to take our word for it it's
essentially what he was saying that
whole time yeah I just want to point out
you know I made this joke downstairs the
absurdity of the establishment narrative
in the modern left in that you guys the
hotep crew because of your politics are
white supremacists
oh yeah and then Serge over here the
white guy is an African-American but
like so we talk about it with Luke
gradkowski all the time because he's
Slavic he's polish yeah and they
consider Slavs people of color so if he
came out and supported their ideology
they would quite literally call this
blonde hair blue-eyed man a person of
color then they would call you guys
white supremacists for your political
views yeah like the the logic does not
make sense and I guess in this context
what I'm trying to get to is they don't
even have Arguments for a lot of their
things they have just
they they go to they go to the cult
members and say
someone's like hey I was told the sky is
blue I looked up and the sky was blue
what's happening I thought the sky was
supposed to be green and they go oh it's
green yeah and they go it is it is yeah
don't worry and they go Okay I accept I
accept that you said that to me right
well it works like the court system
where if somebody's going to give you a
testimony you have to discredit the
witness they don't actually dispute the
evidence they just discredit the witness
that's that's that's something that you
see a lot like that a lot of times
people on social media they're
performing for the people that are
watching yeah so the actual like it
doesn't matter if they have a lot of
substance in what they're saying it's
can they persuade the the people that
are watching and a lot of times they're
only trying to persuade Their audience
so they know what Their audience is
expecting so if they can go ahead and
deliver the the punch line for Their
audience it's a win for it doesn't
matter if there's actually substance to
the argument yes to your point HJ for
example with this this project Veritas
thing right they're not going to argue
what they heard in the in the video
right what they're going to say is I
can't believe they trapped him like that
yeah I can't believe they got video
hidden camera this is not right they
can't do that that's what they're going
to do they're gonna they're gonna go for
that part of it or although they'll call
you know James O'Keefe for a right-wing
guy right right wing extremist they'll
put some sort of label some stench uh
some filth on them some stank they put a
little bit of stank on it I like how
James O'Keefe goes after Google and
Pfizer and they're like well that's
right wing he goes after the uh Epstein
story with uh the the journalist from
ABC Amy robach they're like well he's a
conservative and it's just like what
about opposing massive corporations big
Tech monopolies pharmaceutical companies
and trafficking Rings is a conservative
position I don't understand it's a weird
thing to claim okay
so Liberals are in favor of big Tech
monopolies big pharmaceutical companies
and Epstein's trafficking ring
it's not liberals anymore it's
authoritarians versus like the Liberals
are the people that are actually you
know four liberal principals the people
that are that are you know against Free
Speech or whatever like that they're
authoritarian thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time